There's nothing quite like a great science
fiction movie, and, according to Metacritic,
these are the very best of the best.
Here's the question, though: how many have
you seen?
"You've taken your first step into a larger
world."
Star Wars: Perhaps you've heard of it.
The 1977 original that we now call A New Hope
turned Hollywood completely upside down, becoming
the highest-grossing film of all time and
holding that record until it was dethroned
by E.T. in 1982.
The initial critical response was mixed, but
the masses who spoke so loudly with their
wallets have since been vindicated with near-universal
acclaim in hindsight.
Today, the movie holds a score of 90 on Metacritic.
Star Wars represented a quantum leap forward
in filmmaking technology, dazzling audiences
with visual effects the likes of which they'd
never seen.
But neat tricks aren't the only driving force
behind director George Lucas' greatest achievement.
This is a fictional world that feels so real
that viewers can't help but become absorbed
in it.
Certainly, there's no greater example of science
fiction's escapist appeal — or its versatility
as a genre — than Star Wars.
The movie combines elements of war epics,
classic Spaghetti Westerns, and sword-and-sorcery
fantasy into a sci-fi setting that really
does have something for everyone.
In the future of Mad Max, an ecological disaster
has left Earth bone-dry, and the survivors
of the apocalypse now battle over the remaining
supplies of water and oil.
Between the 1979 original Mad Max and its
two sequels in the 1980s, each film in the
series upped the ante on grim yet stylish
over-the-top action.
In 2015, however, director George Miller took
things to a whole new level with Mad Max:
Fury Road.
The fourth film in the franchise is an intense,
non-stop chase movie in which hard-luck hero
Max Rockatansky teams up with the devastatingly
cool Imperator Furiosa.
Together, they help five women escape slavery
at the hands of a revolting despot.
Fury Road is a top-notch action movie with
eye-popping stunts and practical effects and
award-winning costume and production design.
These qualities alone were enough to earn
it high praise from critics upon release,
of course, but Fury Road has also been held
up as a feminist film, too, tackling themes
and issues rarely found in action movies.
"You cannot own a human being!
Sooner or later, someone pushes back!"
The film's combination of brains, compassion,
and pure adrenaline led to the kind of major
awards recognition that genre flicks rarely
receive, too, as well as a near-perfect Metascore
of 90.
It now stands as an example of how sci-fi
can educate and empower as well as entertain.
Not every great science fiction film is a
blockbuster hit.
Indeed, Russian director Aleksei German's
2013 adaptation of the Strugatsky rothers'
novel Hard to Be a God grossed just under
$1.3 million worldwide.
It is an opaque and difficult watch even in
the eyes of those who love it.
AV Club critic Ignatiy Vishnevetsky wrote:
"If Hard to Be a God isn't the filthiest,
most fetid-looking movie ever made, it's certainly
in the top three."
Meanwhile, The Guardian's Peter Bradshaw asked
in his five-star review:
"What on earth does it mean?"
But, if the film's Metacritic score of 90
is anything to go by, Hard to Be a God is
a challenge worth accepting.
The plot reads like a cautionary tale out
of a classic Star Trek episode, though the
novel predates the series by a few years.
A team of scientists is dispatched to an Earth-like
planet whose social and technological development
are centuries behind our own, held back by
a stubborn and violent anti-intellectualism.
The protagonists are tasked with anonymously
kick-starting the culture's progress, an effort
that is repeatedly met with disaster and disappointment.
Do not approach Hard to Be a God expecting
anything conventional.
The Telegraph's Robbie Collin warns that the
film "[refuses] to take any recognizably plot-like
shape," but assures that an open-minded viewer
will find it, quote, "exhilarating, moving,
funny, beautiful, and unshakeable."
In the early 1930s, Hollywood brought to life
a parade of movie monsters who remain firmly
in the public consciousness even today.
But one stands taller above all the rest.
"Oh, no.
It wasn't the airplanes.
'Twas beauty killed the beast."
King Kong was the first great movie monster
to be created solely for the big screen, rather
than having been adapted from literature or
mythology.
And sure, inventing a really big ape may not
have been the wildest leap of the imagination,
but the story of the 1933 movie, as well as
the technology invented to execute it, has
held the attention of cinephiles for the better
part of a century.
Effects supervisor Willis O'Brien brought
King Kong's titular character and his dinosaur
foes to life by employing practically every
special effects trick that had been invented:
stop motion, matte paintings, rear-screen
projection, miniatures, and giant puppets.
And he combined them with live-action photography
in a more seamless manner than had ever been
seen before.
King Kong was met with instant critical and
commercial success, and despite a string of
sequels, remakes, and reboots, the 1933 original
still reigns supreme with its Metascore of 90.
Viewer beware, though, that King Kong was
very much made in 1933.
In the decades since, some scholars and critics
have come to see the film as a racist allegory,
and while the film's co-directors denied any
such intent, it's certainly not difficult
to read it that way.
Originally released as a trilogy of shorts,
It's Such a Beautiful Day is a mixed-media
film built around pen-and-paper stick figure
animations that, despite their simple forms,
are remarkably expressive and sympathetic.
The film tells the story of Bill, a man coping
with a brain disease that is gradually destroying
his memory and eroding his grip on reality.
The story is told in a stream-of-consciousness
style that takes the audience closely into
Bill's thoughts as he examines his life, his
family history, and the nature of existence.
Remarkably, this animated film is the product
of a single creator, Don Hertzfeldt, from
its hand-drawn character performances to its
narration and sound effects.
It's Such a Beautiful Day is also a brutally
dark comedy, one so dark that it's actually
hard to call it a comedy at all.
Indeed, Vulture's Bilge Ebiri calls it one
of the saddest films he's ever seen, but nevertheless
ranks it among the best films of the 2010s.
In a 2020 retrospective, Ebiri wrote:
"Hertzfeldt's attention to the fleeting glories
of existence makes you feel one with the universe."
But along with being profound, It's Such a
Beautiful Day is also a deeply intimate film
that makes you empathize with its crudely
drawn protagonist on a level you might not
think possible.
It holds a score of 90 on Metacritic, where
it is also ranked as the 20th greatest animated
film of all time.
In Andrei Tarkovsky's 1972 film Solaris, a
psychologist is sent to investigate a space
station whose entire crew has suffered some
sort of emotional breakdown.
While initially dismissing their reports of
bizarre visions as mere hallucinations, the
psychologist soon finds himself face to face
with his late wife.
What is she, really?
Has the strange ocean planet below somehow
reunited them, or is she some sort of illusion?
And even if she isn't real, can't they still
be in love?
Solaris draws easy comparisons to 2001: A
Space Odyssey, another slow, deliberate, and
visually stunning art film set in space.
But, as Roger Ebert wrote in a retrospective
review:
"[2001] is outward, charting man's next step
in the universe, while [Solaris] is inward,
asking about the nature and reality of the
human personality."
The film has an intriguing sci-fi conceit
in its titular sentient planet, which attempts
to communicate to the humans above using their
own memories.
But as in most great speculative fiction,
the otherworldly element is just a device
through which to explore character, and by
extension, the audience.
Solaris premiered at the 1972 Cannes Film
Festival, where it won the Grand Prix Spécial
du Jury and was nominated for the Palme d'Or.
An American remake was produced in 2002, directed
by Steven Soderbergh, but is not as highly
regarded, with a Metascore of 65 to the Tarkovsky
version's 90.
In Steven Spielberg's 1977 movie Close Encounters
of the Third Kind, electrician Roy Neary becomes
obsessed with the search for extraterrestrial
life after having a run-in with a low-flying
UFO.
Neary discovers that he and a number of other
UFO witnesses have been sharing strange visions,
leading them on a daring quest for the truth.
"Have you recently had a close encounter?"
"[French]"
"A close encounter with something very unusual?"
While not a marathon of effects-heavy set
pieces like Star Wars, which was released
that same year, Close Encounters nevertheless
features one of the most arresting finales
in sci-fi history.
Above all, this is an adventure story — one
that's light on action but heavy on suspense,
intrigue, and wonder, keeping the story grounded
in the point of view of everyday people.
In a contemporary review of the movie, Gary
Arnold of The Washington Post wrote:
"Spielberg seems to be whispering, 'This is
going to scare you, but don't be afraid.'
Spielberg puts on an enchanting magic show,
springing one sensuous and sentimental highlight
after another."
Authentic performances, groundbreaking effects,
and a gorgeous John Williams score have made
Close Encounters an enduring favorite among
critics, and it now boasts a Metascore of 90.
The film was nominated for seven Academy Awards,
winning for cinematography and sound effects editing.
In 1980, after seeing Spielberg's revised
Special Edition of the film, Roger Ebert called
it, quote, "one of the great moviegoing experiences."
Many of the highest-scoring sci-fi films on
Metacritic like to show their audiences something
grand and awe-inspiring, but Spike Jonze's
2013 drama Her focuses on something much smaller:
your cellphone.
Joaquin Phoenix plays a lonely man who falls
in love with Samantha, the self-aware operating
system on his phone and computer.
The film takes a realistic and down-to-earth
approach to its premise, fleshing out the
romance before gradually broadening its scope
to examine the grander implications of bringing
a thinking, feeling artificial intelligence
into the world.
Her wrings a lot of humor and pathos out of
its bizarre yet relatable premise, raising
questions not only about our culture's increasing
dependence on technology, but also on how
we relate to each other as human beings.
What do we, or should we, look for in love?
How much of love is about the other person,
and how much is selfish?
What happens when one partner needs the other
more?
And all of these questions are centered around
an awkward introvert and the shiny rectangle
he carries in his pocket, brought to life
by terrific, committed performances by Phoenix
and his co-star, Scarlet Johannsson.
On top of awarding it a Metascore of 90, Metacritic
found that Her topped 22 different lists of
critics' favorite films of 2013.
Her was also nominated for five Academy Awards,
including Best Picture, and brought home the
prestigious Oscar for Best Original Screenplay.
Few sci-fi films hold such a treasured place
in the hearts of '80s kids as Steven Spielberg's
E.T.
the Extra-Terrestrial.
Released in the spring of 1982, E.T.
was a massive success, drawing in families
in such droves that it supplanted Star Wars
as the highest-grossing film of all time.
Like Spielberg's other sci-fi films, E.T.
features moments of eerie suspense and exciting
adventure, but it also has something going
for it that most genre blockbusters don't:
It's adorable.
"E.T. home phone…"
E.T.
tells the story of Elliot Taylor, played by
10-year-old Henry Thomas, and a benign alien
visitor represented by an advanced animatronic
and performed by a variety of puppeteers and
costumed actors.
Made long before CGI became the norm, E.T.
is so emotive and charismatic that it takes
no time to forget that he's just a special
effect.
And when his time on Earth takes a toll on
E.T.'s health, you'll likely find yourself
genuinely concerned, even anguished with worry
over his well-being.
Don't worry — everyone else felt the same
way.
E.T. was a hit with critics upon its release, and
continues to tug on their heartstrings today.
In 2012, Christy Lemire of The Philadelphia
Inquirer wrote:
"How old is too old to sob like a little girl
at E.T.
the Extra-Terrestrial?
Not 40, apparently."
The film holds a Metascore of 91.
Hailing from Thai director Apichatpong Weerasethakul
, Memoria is perhaps one of the most enigmatic
sci-fi films of all time.
It debuted in July 2021 at the Cannes Film
Festival, where it was awarded the Jury Prize,
one of the event's highest honors — but
its theatrical release has been extremely limited.
Still, those critics who have seen it have
heaped praise aplenty upon the film, winning
it a Metascore of 91.
Polygon's Robert Daniels warns that the movie
is a little metaphor-heavy, but nevertheless
writes:
"Memoria is a sensory explosion, and its dense,
immersive shrapnel isn’t easily removable."
Memoria is the story of Jessica, a Scottish
woman living in Colombia, who is haunted by
a thunderous recurring sound that only she
can hear — but this isn't so much a mystery
as it is a character study and existential
meditation.
All in all, Memoria may not be every sci-fi
enthusiast's cup of tea, of course, but it's
a must-see for fans of art house cinema…
that is, if it's ever playing near you.
Mary Shelley's 1818 novel Frankenstein has
been described as the first true work of science
fiction, a tale of science gone wrong with
a strong moral and emotional core.
You likely know the story well — Dr. Frankenstein
attempts to conquer death by constructing
a new man from the bodies of the dead and
reanimating his tissue via advanced chemistry.
"It's alive, it's alive, oh, it's alive!
It's alive, it's alive!"
His Creature does indeed come to life, but
is shunned by society for his imposing figure
and his unnatural origins, leading to a tragic
and violent ending.
Nothing has boosted the cultural impact of
Shelley's tale so much as director James Whale's
1931 film adaptation, which redefined the
story and characters of Frankenstein into
the iconic tale most familiar to the public
today.
Boris Karloff's performance as the shambling,
wordless Creature, as well as his iconic appearance
by makeup artist Jack Pierce, are now inseparable
from the character.
Later film adaptations featuring an eloquent,
intelligent Creature now just feel wrong,
despite being more accurate to the source
material.
Karloff even went on to reprise the role in
three sequels.
Frankenstein's impact on Hollywood was felt
instantly.
In his review for The New York Times, Mordaunt
Hall called the film, quote, "far and away
the most effective thing of its kind."
Nearly a century later, critics still consider
Frankenstein one of the pinnacles of both
sci-fi and horror, and it stands tall today
with a Metascore of 91.
Werckmeister Harmonies is a Hungarian art
film from directors Béla Tarr and Ágnes
Hranitzky, in which the arrival of a bizarre
traveling circus prompts a small town to descend
into madness and despair.
The circus is led by a shadowy figure called
The Prince, whose face is never shown but
whose words propel the townsfolk towards an
unnerving and inevitable revolution.
The story is told from the perspective of
a benign and thoughtful young man who, along
with his two elderly uncles, becomes the target
of the town's new regime.
Werckmeister Harmonies is 145 minutes long
and contains only 38 cuts; apparently, if
there weren't physical limitations on how
much film his camera could store at a time,
Tarr claims he would have made each take even
longer.
These unbroken shots embed the audience deeply
into the setting and force them to mingle
with the characters, even following them around
as they walk silently through the town for
minutes at a time.
Roger Ebert wrote of this style of filmmaking:
"Béla Tarr's style seems to be an attempt
to regard his characters with great intensity
and respect, to observe them without jostling
them, to follow unobtrusively as they move
through their worlds, which look so ordinary
and are so awesome, like ours."
While seen by relatively few filmgoers, Werckmeister
Harmonies is adored by critics.
In his review, Lawrence Van Gelder of The
New York Times called it, quote, "mysterious,
poetic and allusive [...] Flowing like a torturous
dream."
Critical consensus has awarded this film a
Metascore of 92.
Science fiction can often be aspirational,
showing audiences a future they'd like to
live in and even suggesting ways they might
get there.
It can also serve the exact opposite purpose,
however — warning the public of the dangers
of their current path and appealing to them
to change course before it's too late.
Threads, a documentary-style film produced
for the BBC in 1984, is an unflinching, unblinking
portrayal of nuclear war designed for one
purpose: to terrify its audience into action.
According to a 2009 interview with The Scotsman,
director Mick Jackson claimed he felt that
the threat of nuclear annihilation was so
enormous that people lacked the vocabulary
to even comprehend it.
With Threads, he hoped to turn his extensive
research into something visceral and brutal
that would help its audience put words and
images to their fear.
The story extends far beyond the events of
a nuclear bombing itself into the months and
years that follow, depicting suffering on
an unimaginable scale.
Even decades later, Threads makes for one
of the most disturbing movie experiences of
all time.
In 2012, The Guardian's Peter Bradshaw wrote:
"The only film I have been really and truly
scared and indeed horrified by [...] is Mick
Jackson’s post-nuclear apocalypse movie
Threads."
This visceral look at an alternate past — and
a potential future — scores a 92 rating
on Metacritic.
In the 1950s, alien invasion stories were
all the rage in Hollywood, and for obvious
reason, too.
It was the nuclear age, a time when the wonders
of outer space felt closer than ever — as
did the threat of conquest by those devious
Soviets.
Extraterrestrials on film became a way to
personify this cultural anxiety or to criticize
it.
Depending on who you ask, the original 1956
version of Invasion of the Body Snatchers
does both… or neither.
"Can't you see, they're after you!
They're after all of us!
Our wives, our children, everyone!
They're here already!"
Invasion of the Body Snatchers is a thriller
following two suburbanites who discover that
their neighbors are being secretly replaced,
one by one, with identical copies of alien
origin bent on world conquest.
The tension grows as they begin to question
whether there's anyone left in town who are
still who they appear to be.
Jack Finney, the author of the novel on which
the film is based, claimed that there was
no political purpose behind his story at all,
but the film is nonetheless soaked in the
paranoia of its day.
Time Out's 2014 retrospective review explains:
"From fascism to communism to capitalist conformity
[...] this is the perfect distillation of
uncanny existential terror."
Critics thought little of Invasion of the
Body Snatchers in 1956, but, generations later,
it has risen to a Metascore of 92.
WALL-E is a visually stunning computer-animated
film with a heart of gold and something truly
worthwhile to say.
The brainchild of director Andrew Stanton
and the celebrated Pixar animation studio,
WALL-E's titular character is one of Earth's
last "living" inhabitants, and has one programmed
purpose — to crush garbage into compact,
stackable cubes.
After years in isolation, however, he grows
beyond his programming, dreaming of romance
and adventure.
WALL-E gets his wish when he discovers a living
plant among the ruins of our spoiled planet
and falls in love with EVE, the advanced probe
tasked with returning the plant to humanity's
new home in space.
Throughout their journey, the film dazzles
with beautiful animation and production design
and comments on modern consumerism and reliance
on technology, all the while remaining a romantic
comedy at heart.
WALL-E drew instant critical acclaim upon
its release.
New York Magazine's David Edelstein wrote:
"The new Pixar picture WALL-E is one for the
ages, a masterpiece to be savored before or
after the end of the world."
It was nominated for seven Academy Awards,
winning Best Animated Feature, and with a
Metascore of 95, ranks in Metacritic's top
10 animated features of all time.
Director James Whale's Frankenstein shocked
new life into both horror and science fiction
in 1931, but it's his sequel, 1935's The Bride
of Frankenstein, that stands as his true masterpiece;
it now holds a Metascore of 95, besting the
original by four points.
In Bride of Frankenstein, Dr. Frankenstein's
mentor Dr. Pretorius coerces him into harvesting
more dead bodies with which to create a mate
for the lonely Creature.
"She's alive!"
Meanwhile, the Creature wanders the countryside
searching for meaning or companionship, only
to have it stolen from him at every opportunity
by closed-minded citizens.
The Bride of Frankenstein builds on the horror
of the first film while also adding a charming
sense of self-awareness and humor.
Whale mines both scares and laughs from the
Creature's misadventures, and Dr. Pretorius
is camp incarnate.
The film is also full of moments and images
that have since become so iconic that some
may assume they originated in the previous
film, such as the Creature's grunts and broken
speech or his friendly encounter with the
blind hermit.
The Bride herself, with her statically charged
hairdo, is one of the most famous figures
of the genre despite appearing only briefly
in the film.
Initially praised as merely "a first-rate
horror film," The Bride of Frankenstein is
now regarded as a true classic of the genre.
People want movies to take them places, and
that goes doubly for sci-fi movies.
The 2013 movie Gravity takes its viewers to
the deadly and beautiful reaches of Earth's
orbit — and then holds them there, relentlessly,
for about 90 minutes.
The film stars Sandra Bullock as Dr. Ryan
Stone, an astronaut whose spacewalk is interrupted
when a sudden barrage of orbital debris destroys
her shuttle.
Alone in the vacuum of space, Dr. Stone must
find a way to rendezvous with another craft
before her air runs out or the debris field
comes back around.
Director Alfonso Cuarón's took great pains
to keep the audience totally immersed in the
events of the film.
The story plays out in just about real-time,
and with as few cuts as possible.
In particular, Gravity begins with a 13-minute
continuous take that sets the tone for the
entire film, in which the camera floats through
space and rarely leaves Ryan's side.
The technological challenges of creating Gravity
meant it took over four years to complete,
and the final product stands up as one of
the greatest examples of what IMAX 3D can
bring to a film.
Much of what you see in the movie is computer-generated,
but Bullock's performance is very real, and
it even earned her an Academy Award nomination
for Best Actress.
The film would go on to win seven Oscars,
including Best Director for Cuarón, and maintains
an astronomical Metascore of 96.
With a Metascore of 98, Metacritic's highest-scoring
science fiction film dates all the way back
to 1927, during the first golden age of cinema.
The brainchild of German director Fritz Lang
and novelist Thea von Harbou, Metropolis is
the story of a conflict between the suffering
workers and the pampered ruling class of a
massive futuristic city.
Much of the story centers around Freder, the
son of the city's "master" who joins with
the workers when he learns of their plight.
The star of the show, however, is Brigitte
Helm in the dual role of Maria, the kind-hearted
leader of the workers, and the Maschinenmensch,
the wicked robot created in her image to incite
a war between the factions.
Metropolis wasn't exactly a critical smash
when it was first released, though.
New York Times film critic Mordaunt Hall wrote:
"It is a technical marvel with feet of clay,
a picture as soulless as the manufactured
woman of its story."
But later generations were kinder to the film,
fixating on its revolutionary special effects
and unique production design.
Scarcity also contributed to the legacy of
Metropolis, as only abbreviated cuts were
available for most of the 20th century.
Its 2003 restoration was celebrated by modern
film critics, however, leading to its near-perfect Metascore.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.